[Music]
you audition for sarin out live I did
four years ago how many years ago was
that it was nine years ago
okay Wow you have a laser-like memory
for that that's right you didn't get the
gig but it I didn't you didn't get it
they usually play to tell they usually
wait nine years before telling you but
but your tape got around there's a lot
of really fun stuff on your tape yeah
did my excuse me I needed some of that I
am probably recognized more for that
here in town by other actors it's got it
kind of went viral it's out there people
see it yes and actors will come up to me
in auditions and go hey man my manager
told me to watch your failed audition
tape brezin oh yeah you did impressions
on it you did like Johnny Cash I did a
little Johnny Iranian Kristofferson
actually split screen right talking
about lawn darts right and you did they
were huge and what would you say it was
the part it was at your Matthew
McConaughey was probably the part that
people like the most people know me for
my McConaughey what people really loved
in the in the audition tape though is my
Denzel a lot of people don't know a
small Jewish white man can do Denzel and
what they don't know is that I'm not
doing Denzel Denzel is doing me you
understand you want to come out he wants
to play when he wants to play right so
that's your dad that's really it's
better on the audition tape that didn't
get me on to SNL yeah anyway can we hear
some of the McConaughey I'd love to hear
that absolutely what do you what do you
want to hear just any I mean anything
what do you what do you want to do you I
mean I have problems now because
McConaughey's become such a serious
actor he's an Oscar winner now right and
I really he became more he became sort
of a more of a more krabi toss yeah
exactly and I really enjoyed McConaughey
when he was more of the memo the naked
Bongo playing
stoned McConaughey who would say things
like only reason I put a shirt on is so
I can take it off does it make sense for
anyone but him
right because it is enjoyable to watch
him take it whereas me that's when the
impression dies yeah I take it off your
leg that's not you did I'm right you've
done you've done a lot of theater you've
done Shakespeare yeah done a little
Shakespeare back in the day I actually
have been working on an idea with Makani
and Shakespeare takes McConaughey doing
Shakespeare Cana he performing a little
bit of Shakespeare if you guys want to
hear some yeah might as well give it a
shot sure go ahead
what are we gonna hear now what's great
shakes this is from this is a this is a
piece from Richard ii okay a speech
about him coming home and finding that
all of his possessions have been taken
this does not matter what it's about
alright so McConaughey richard ii
alright alright oh no no matter where of
comfort no man speak but ladies let me
hear you love them ladies let's talk of
graves bummer of worms slimy an epitaph
that's a cool word make dust our paper
and with rainy eyes right sorrow on the
bosom of the earth because everybody
loves some TIG old bitties coming
[Applause]
mr. Bharat intended since it's a barge
intended in and Makani now when he sees
this is gonna go
Shakespeare that's Shakespeare not the
one
you